and Luke Busan was in town and I'm  telling him about my big miniseries and  glorious bastards that I'm gonna do it  looks like you you are one of the few  filmmakers left out there that makes me  want to leave my house  and go to a cinema anybody else like uh  watching the DVD I can see it on TV it'd  be fine I'm I'm good but you know you  make me want to leave the house and go  see Cinema and now you tell me I'm going  to have to wait four years before I can  do that again I'm sorry I'm not so  excited and you know  every once in a while somebody tells you  something somebody says something to you  that you can never unhear and once he  said that I couldn't unhear it and I  kept thinking about it and I kept  thinking about it and I kept thinking  about it this is my time to do movies  let me try one more time  to make it a movie don't just throw up  my hands and say I give up and make this  incredibly sprawling epic let me try one  more time